faltan cinco meses para los juegos
olímpicos de tokio y el evento deportivo
se quedó sin presidente yoshiro mori
quien lideraba el proyecto de las
olimpiadas dimitió en medio de una
oleada de críticas por unos comentarios
sexistas que dijo durante una reunión
efectivamente a partir de hoy dimito
como presidente lo importante es que las
olimpiadas sucedan en julio y no puedo
permitir que mi presencia complique las
preparaciones
político quinto
morir se quejó de las reuniones donde
hay muchas mujeres argumentando que
duran más tiempo porque hablan demasiado
el propio comité olímpico de tokio tiene
cinco mujeres entre sus 24 integrantes
estas declaraciones levantaron polémica
las mismas autoridades japonesas
criticaron con dureza amor y quien
inicialmente solo se disculpó pero no
renunció a su cargo
con la presión japonesa internacional y
también de la opinión pública el
presidente decidió dar un paso al lado
creo que la renuncia es lo correcto era
vergonzoso para japón es algo bueno morí
ex primer ministro de 83 años deja los
juegos en un momento delicado casi la
mitad de los japoneses opinan que el
evento debería volver a posponerse por
la pandemia además no hay un sucesor
claro para hacerse cargo del liderazgo
de las olimpiadas unas olimpiadas que no
dejan de encontrar tropiezos por el
camino